there's been a mix of anticipation and
impatience for Disney and Marvel to
announce their plans to possibly
continue the Deadpool film series but
unfortunately Deadpool co-creator Rob
Liefeld isn't particularly enthusiastic
on that front in an appearance on
comic-book coms talking shop
the superstar comic artist didn't mince
words but I'm glad we talked about
Deadpool 3 I blame Marvel blame Marvel
but that hasn't happened yet
Liefeld doubled down in a separate
interview with inverse calling himself a
realist about the future of both
Deadpool 3 and the planned x-force film
he said they've quote set sail
Liefeld said he thinks Marvel is
dragging its feet with Deadpool after
the first two movies came out within
just two years of each other a really
quick turnaround for a big-budget
superhero sequel he claimed that under
Marvel even if Deadpool 3 went into
production right this very moment it
would take four years to be released why
would it take so long to make because
according to Liefeld Marvel isn't
thinking about the Deadpool franchise at
all right now he said he didn't say
whether he had insider information or if
that was just a guess but Liefeld
advised all deadpool fans to enjoy the
previous two movies and simply do what
he does I'm living in the past man
he also said he isn't impressed with MCU
mastermind Kevin Feige at the moment
we're all like all Marvel they're the
best oh really you killed off the Oni
jr. you say goodbye to Chris Evans you
said Scarlett Johansson off a cliff
Liefeld likewise threw shade at Marvel's
conclusion to phase 3 and its plans for
phase 4 while speaking with inverse he
cited the black widow prequel which
presents no real suspense given that
it's a prequel and spider-man actor Tom
Hollands brief exit from the MCU
following contract disputes with Sony
Pictures as evidence of Marvel's
shortcomings I'm not really that crazy
about Marvel's plan right now it's the
first time I go hey finally did you he
continued your plan was Eternals and
shang-chi that was your plan and a black
widow
they almost lose Tom Hall and to Sony
but you're geniuses Marvel you're
geniuses unlike at Fox where the
Deadpool films only had to fit loosely
within the much smaller
narrative scope of the x-men franchise
Deadpool now has to carve out space for
itself within a massive storytelling
enterprise more than a decade and 23
films in the making the property and the
character alike also must align with
Disney and Marvel's family-friendly vibe
most Marvel movies have been rated pg-13
and aside from some action movie
violence and a mild four-letter word
here in there they've mostly been safe
for kids to watch for many that's part
of the appeal of Marvel films and it's a
big reason for the studio's massive
continued financial success the r-rated
Deadpool movies on the other hand aren't
kid-friendly Deadpool as a character is
fundamentally foul-mouthed suggestive
and purposefully over-the-top with his
violent antics and the movies push the
envelope even further than the comics do
fans have worried about whether Marvel
would have to change Deadpool to
accommodate the MCU tone Bob Iger the
then CEO of the Walt Disney Company
stated in February twenty nineteen that
any future Deadpool movie wouldn't be
toned down and would still be r-rated
even under the Disney Marvel banner
he told variety we will continue in that
business he noted that there's certain
popularity with r-rated comic book
movies like Deadpool and Deadpool - but
I gir also said that Disney and Marvel
would have to take steps to make sure
kids didn't think a Deadpool movie was
like an Avengers movie will be carefully
branding r-rated films so we're not in
any way confusing the consumer now that
I gur has stepped down as CEO and Bob
Capek has taken his place it's difficult
to say if the promises Eiger made still
apply it's almost unthinkable that
Disney and Marvel Studios would let the
Deadpool property molder on the Shelf
indefinitely Fox's first - Deadpool
films were some of the most successful
in the history of the x-men franchise
and any effort to bring Reynolds popular
portrayal of the character into the MCU
would undoubtedly be met with ample
excitement from the fan base as Liefeld
noted these two movies are a 1.5 billion
dollar franchise on a combined budget of
less than 200 million so will there be a
Deadpool 3 and if so when Liefeld has
his guesses and for now we'll just have
to make hours until Marvel makes an
official announcement check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about the MCU are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]